the championship parade for the Golden
State Warriors was held today in
Auckland and just like in Game six the
Cleveland Cavaliers stayed home yeah
yeah I hear that a new movie rough night
is just footage of the Cavaliers playing
defense Cavalier is more like callaloo
tzer's yeah well I'd just like me in
high school the Cavs couldn't score yeah
I haven't seen I mean the Cavaliers are
more like Andy Andy are you okay has
that ever happened to you you're trading
quips with a friend and suddenly you
can't think of anything funny to say
I mean you blank out completely this guy
look at me I got nothing well good thing
there's the quick wit app quick wit
listens to all your conversations and
automatically compiles dozens of puns
word-plays insults comebacks and sex
references related to your topic
so don't be a nitwit use quick wit I'm
sorry you sure you're okay Andy yeah I
was just thinking about the Cavaliers I
mean I haven't seen that many blown
leads since Hillary Clinton's campaign
get one hand he's really good thanks
Conan and thanks quick wit
[Music]
how the hell did you screw that up I
went the wrong way I love that happened
during a piece called quick wit yeah I
went the wrong way we got a great show
tonight I'm sure it's gonna just keep
you'll see people are filing out right
now from the social network nocturnal
animals and the new movie Cars 3 I
really like this guy Armie Hammer is on
the show
oh you got it now that guy it's like
that guy doesn't like armie hammer host
the new Comedy Central series the Jim
Jefferies Show comedian Jim Jefferies is
on the
when they freeze you mid clap it doesn't
look good no it doesn't I don't think it
looks good for anybody no no freeze me
mid clap and see what look I'm just
curious what it looks like if it can't
do it you're not do it you're not on a
green screen
you go I gotta be on a green Scott I'm
over here and do I've been on TV for 24
years
what yeah
music guests Gavin DeGraw
I want this made into a poster and sold
at the Warner Brothers store
you